travailler dans une étude notariale
c'est la vocation choisi par ses 200
étudiants en bts notariat
ils viennent des lycée marie curie de
versailles ou toulouse-lautrec de
vaucresson particularité de ce dernier
établissement l'accueil d'élèves en
situation de handicap moteur et au cours
des stages si on a j'ai pu avoir
beaucoup de contacts avec la clientèle
et ça va beaucoup intéressé est du coup
assez mal ça va ouvert vers d autres
j'ai toujours eu cette envie d'aller en
notariat et c'est un oui c'est un milieu
que j'aime beaucoup qui relève du droit
j'ai vécu des expériences en devant des
notaires en tant que client avec surtout
mes grands parents et mes parents et je
voulais et je voulais découvrir ce
métier
le droit me plaît énormément car
j'estime que ben on en a besoin dans la
vie quotidienne tous les jours bts
notariat une formation post bac de deux
ans des cours de droit de déontologie ou
de culture générale pour devenir notaire
claire ou encore rédacteur d'actes
c'est l'occasion de leur présenter ce
qu'est la profession ce que sont les
métiers qui sont proposés au sein de nos
études et puis quelques traits
caractéristiques de notre profession
notamment l'impact fort de la
déontologie autres au travers donc de
cette de cette formation il et nous
offrons bon nombre d'emplois et bon
nombre également deux perspectives de
carrière avec de nombreux métiers et des
évolutions possibles les métiers du
notariat représente environ 2700 emplois
sur le territoire de la cour d'appel de
versailles dont près de 1000 dans les
yvelines selon la bourse de l'emploi du
notariat près de 30 postes sont à
pourvoir actuellement dans le
département